ثمانيه اشهر جعلت اطول معركه في اوكرانيا
خسائر الطرفين تعد بالالاف بينما تحسب
المكاسب على الارض بالامتار لكن ما سر
الاصرار على بخمه وزير الدفاع الامريكي
اقلل من اهميه المدينه
كشفت الاسباب واشنطن لا تريد رؤيتك تنجرف
وراء معركه استنزاف الفائز فيها خاسر
التقارير نفسها تحدثت عن رغبه قاده الجيش
الاوكراني في الانسحاب الا ان معارضه
زيلينسكيت اجلت القرار حتى في اوكرانيا
بخموت لم تكن بهذه الاهميه قبل اسابيع
الاعلام الاوكراني تحدث عن تكلفه صمودا
تفوق اهميه بخمس لكن خطابات الاخيره عادت
لتجعله تجعل المدينه حركته الاولى ربما هي
مناوره عسكريه لاستدراج المزيد من القوات
الروسيه زيلينسكي مرر قراره بكون بخم وت
اخر خطوط الدفاع قبل اكراماتورسكو وهو لا
يخفي رغبته في ربح الوقت قبل وصول ليوبارد
الدبابه الالمانيه الا ان بروجين له راي
اخر
الشمس
تحليل يبدو منطقيا لكن هل وقع بروجين
بدوره في الفخ
جعلت من بخموت معركتها الوحيده ولاجلها
تاخذه معركه موازيه ضد وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تنافس تحول الى الصراع وبوتا لا
يزال متفرجا تكلفه الصمود في بخموت لا
تخفيها
تحدث عن مقتل احد عشر الف اوكراني خلال
الشهر الماضي الا انا فايتنر تسعى لتجنيد
المزيد من المساجين بينما تجد اوكرانيا
نفسها امام خسائر قد يصعب تعويضها
[موسيقى]